axes approach to marketing has been one
of the most unique and brilliant
campaigns in history but their marketing
genius has been shrouded by what appears
to just be a cheap tactic advertising
sex but what made act successful was not
what they were advertising instead it
was who they were advertising to and how
they did it by ignoring all social rules
of delicacy love them or hate them acts
as a beautifully consistent brand their
marketing style matches their product
perfectly just like their cheap almost
overpowering leaf fragrant body spray
that punches you in the mouth with its
stench axe is marketed to the male ego
with one singular thought men especially
pubescent boys don't understand subtlety
in fact it may never be possible to be
clear enough and so while other cologne
brands were timidly dancing around the
notion that men wear fragrances to get
women X decided to skip the foreplay and
go for the jugular their brand won't
make you slightly less smelly slightly
more classy or make you fall in love
their brand will get you laid and not
just by one woman but as many women as
you want and no six-pack required you
can be the biggest loser in school but
the second you spray on Axe body spray
you become a chick magnet so powerful it
would make James Bond jealous all for
the low low price of $4.99
but before they launched in America in
2002 as a bottled sex pheromone Axe had
to figure out who they stood for after
all if you try to appeal to everyone do
you appeal to no one so in efforts of
figuring out the perfect audience for
their over-the-top marketing campaign
they decided to do a study ax took
nearly a hundred men out to bars and
watch them try to pick up girls trying
to classify different kinds of potential
acts consumers they eventually realized
that their target audience would not be
the already confident male
they didn't need help getting women they
would sell to the awkward acne faced
average Joe who didn't have a chance but
the kind of guy who blushes at the mere
thought of approaching his crush the
technical term for their audience was
the insecure novice and you can see this
play out in their ads up until now
brands like Old Spice and colognes had
always cast male models to get the
female model but not acts they decided
that with their body spray the dorky
male would get the female model they
casted anybody except the stereotypical
hunk it was the kid with glasses the
average guy who's on an unlucky streak
but as for the female lead they applied
their enough is never enough rule and
Swan dove into the deep end of the Nerds
fantasy life they consistently cast the
perfect tin Amazonia bikini clad female
lead who doesn't care that axe hasn't
transformed you into a hunk you don't
need to be a hunt when you can smell
like a five-dollar can of axe and this
has worked beautifully for a long time
and even right now Access had the lion's
share of the male fragrance industry
with the only real casualty being high
school hallways everywhere but the way
they did it wasn't just selling sex acts
reinvented how to sell sex and who to
sell it to
[Music]